Cái quen nha sẽ lần đầu tham gia thứ thành Cái Chế Anh Hình Tập Thế theo đều năm của Ná Tố trong khu lịch khu tập trận loi yếu đồ lốt,
hành giữ chúng trong hàng băm. Nên giấu bước đi mà lý vụ tượng trong quanh hệ giật kia và lý mình của sự này.
Theo hạc tình tá lẫn của tín vụ tổng tham yếu của quen nha, khoảng 1,5 trăm chuyên gia của sự và dân sự đã tham gia các hoạt động dễ tập trên khắp cho ông.
Trong đó lần đầu có sự có mặt của đại dễ u quen nha trong lối dùng mô phòng Cái phòng thứ Tập Thế của Ná Tố.
Lối đồ lốt hành hệ lắm, là khu tập trận trọc điểm trong chuyên trình phần lựa của Ná Tố năm nay,
tập trung và có hoạt động trên bộ của vời sự thích hợp đã lý vực nhằm kiểm tra khả năng khối hợp và thích ở nữ của các biến tham gia.
Theo Ná Tố, khi nóng của hiến trường Ná Tố, khi nóng của chi trọng của mình chiến,
vừa định vuiu tắc một nứa thành viên vị tần công sẽ được coi là tọn khổ ý vị tần công,
của nó khi khỏa tiêm vụ phố trở tập Thế, u quen nha như lần có việc tiếp cận coi trên này lại lệ lệ lệ tên chốt để bảo đảm án những lâu dài.
Thế đã nục đơn xin ra nhập Ná Tố theo thu dục lúc gọn tuổi thảo chiến năm 2019,
sau ngà phản đứng mệ mẽ cho rằng thác phòng Ná Tố, u quen nha là nguyên nhân đốc dễ của cuộc súc đồ tệ này
và yêu cầu nước này duy trị trạp thái chút lập trọng mọi thật tự lai.